all right welcome back everybody we love
shining a light on people who use their
imaginations to open opportunities for
others so do our friends at Pilot pin
makers of friction the go-to race pin of
the Kelly Clarkson show and that is why
we want to introduce you to our next
guest she has a screen printing company
that not only employs autistic people
but gives them opportunities to create
fearlessly as well from the awesome
company everybody Welcome
Jackie so thank you for being here we're
so what is happening I'm so happy to be
here you're so cool I am not that cool
you will find out but I hear that the
inspiration for this everything is your
son right yes yeah so what happened he
is older now and so I really think that
I'm now my own inspiration seriously
love I'm an Autism mom and uh I
navigated that world like a lot of other
people and I noticed that uh the
autistic kids had a path it's not clear
sometimes it's a little bumpy but it
definitely goes into a line we know what
resources they need support friends but
what I noticed is you know autistic kids
become autistic adults and what happens
and what I saw happen is nothing and it
some of the individuals lives became
smaller and opportunities were kind of
Bleak and I was like seriously just over
it and so I was like well I'm starting
something I don't know what I'm doing
but I don't care so I bought a t-shirt
printing machine and I said hiring
people that uh have autism and we're
going to print shirts for people and
we're going to sell them and the more
t-shirts we sell the more autistic
people I'm going to hire and that's just
what I'm going to do so I just did it
and it's awesome it's incredible and
that's a powerful statement because not
everybody not everybody knows how to do
that they have the idea but you don't
actually it doesn't come to fruition
that's what I think is incredible so so
what let's talk about your employees
though because I do want to I do want to
know you're only able to hire so many
right so that's kind of one of the
issues is you're wanting to hire more
but you found a way to navigate around
that right yes well I was kind of at a
Crossroads where I have a great group of
people that work for me and we have
about 12 full-time employees and do I
invest in them or do I just keep
bringing more people in no I'm going to
invest in my team because I want them to
feel valued respected safe important so
they stay with me and I hold their hand
and I seriously don't let go and the
guys that you're going to meet they'll
confirm that I'm obsessed with them like
I want them to stay with for but we do
have a couple positions that are always
open for individuals to come and try uh
the interview process is the hardest
part of being an autistic adult you get
nervous freak out you don't know how to
communicate you need a little bit more
time so for me I leave two spots open
for people to come in wherever they are
in the Spectrum and they can work on
skills they can work on a job for the
summer because they have a dream job
that they want some like work on their
resume I am like a One-Stop shop like
just come to me we'll make it happen
yeah but it's so great it's like a
home like I realized that more people
with Autism I wanted to help more people
and I wanted to employ them and I
couldn't figure out how to do it and
then I realized a lot of people that wer
messaging me were artists and graphic
designers and I said well I have an art
background I used to own an art gallery
you can do this and so I put out uh a
recruitment for autistic artists to
submit their artwork for me and I put it
on it's all wearable art so you can go
to our website you can see all the
artistic artists work and I paid for all
of their designs so they get paid and
with every items sold they get royalties
so I just
incredible like that's important right
the important part of it is also payment
is without a doubt the most important
thing to me and uh the spectrum is large
and there's you'll when you meet someone
with autism you've met just one person
with autism so there's all kinds of
people on the Spectrum but some people
need more support and maybe they don't
quite get that they just made 15 bucks
that hour but maybe when they go to the
store later and they buy something like
sorry they they realize that they earned
that yeah it's like so important to me
it really is important to feel that you
have purpose like that impact must you
must see that written on your faces just
valued friendship yeah someone you can
count on but like the communication like
sure maybe you're not doing the regular
communication everyone knows that we all
have each other's back and like the
world can be kind of scary and like ours
isn't yeah I love that the awesome
company focuses on hiring autistic
employees to screen print t-shirts and
other items that are made to order we
have two of those staff members joining
us now everybody give a big hello to
Brian and
Matt so hello how are youall doing thank
you for coming thank you for having us
absolutely I like your shirt I like is
this did are these shirts youall made oh
yeah oh yeah they're pretty awesome
they're pretty awesome I know I got to
give it so so Matt I'm going to start
with you like how did you how did you
come across this how did you the awesome
company so I was bouncing around from
jobs trying to find something that's
stuck but nothing was open in
understanding of autism and then one day
I heard Jackie here was recruiting
people on the Spectrum and so I thought
I'll apply went in and haven't I've been
there since for 5 years now oh my
God that has to change your life it
changed my life you know when first of
all you surround yourself with people
you want to work with on a daily and
then also just having a job that you
enjoy and you feel purpose and that had
to change your life right what do it
like now it it feels amazing just waking
up going in there knowing that I'm going
to see the same people every day and
that you know if I'm having a problem or
a great day I can always talk to Jackie
or Brian or you know whoever's there
yeah it just made me feel happy to know
that I found a new home
yeah I love it
well Brian now I want to talk to you so
what's a typical day like for you well
there is no typical day at the awesome
company one day I could be out passing
out marketing bags to business districts
um another day could be out cutting film
to print on shirts uh another day I can
be writing thank you notes we write
these handwritten thank you notes oh
that's awesome that our penmanship is
key it's it's a lot it really is a lost
start I know it is
we do thank you card here I do that for
for people here that's awesome too we
decided that we wanted to connect with
our community in a world that you kind
of feel distant from people so every
single person that buys a t-shirt from
us or a garment custom apparel they
receive a handwritten note from us
saying thank you so much for letting us
earn your business and please tell your
friends about us and it really is a
great job but also we're connecting with
the community and we're getting so much
good love back and it's just wonderful
so he's you're you have the best
penmanship I think oh yeah
absolutely
yeah oh well Matt does some design work
and he made a special piece that he
wanted to share so is this oh yes we
have to we have a little surprise for
you so oh it's for me it's for you right
when we found out that we were going to
be here I said Matt you got to make her
a drawing and we research what you loved
so we realized you liked sunflowers
cobalt blue is her favorite and like we
heard that you might be a good
research it's a specific color Matt made
this for you oh my gosh I love it a
sunflower with the music
notes
oh and to show what we what we do at the
awesome company is we put that artwork
on some clothes for you to wear oh my
gosh thank
you I want to see awesome company with
you oh my God I'm going to open it now
I'm so excited this is so awesome so
well awesome I didn't mean me to
that that is so
nice oh my
gosh well I have something for all of
you as well so our season long partner
pilot pen wants to celebrate people
creating fearlessly and awesomely like
all of you so they're hooking you up
with all sorts of pins and supplies to
help empower the artist within and
behind the awesome company and also I
just believe in this so much and I just
am so proud of like everything that is
being accomplished here and all the
purpose and the impact on the community
I can meas as well so I'm going to give
$5,000 just to help
out I think it's so
amazing and I heard that you're wanting
to do a gallery right so that's what I
was just going to say is like I heard
about the Galler the universe is like
exploding my soul open right now because
I thought we have our autistic artist
and we have the wearable art but like I
don't see uh any Art Gallery that's
dedicated to autistic artists only so
I'm open open one oh my gosh this is
incredible I heard about that so I'm I'm
very excited about that we are going to
use this we're going to use the pens and
money to help with that thank you so
much oh my God absolutely well everybody
we need a short break you're doing great
when you're crying it means it matters
it's
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thank you guys have a great night
I'm going
home